على دراجته
عندما انفجر صاروخ عبوات وقود
بالقرب
من سيارة إسعاف جلبت سلطانًا إلى تركيا
، كان هو ووالدته هناك
منذ أن هذه هي آخر صورة
للسلطان قبل الغارة الجوية
لا ، أنت لست قبيحًا ، أنت جميل ،
أخبره أحمد باستمرار أن سلطان لديه
ابتسامة مجردة تمامًا بعيون
تتأرجح بين متلألئة مثل
طفل يبلغ من العمر عشر سنوات ،
ولكن في بعض الأحيان يغمق مع حلول ماضيه
في هذه الكوابيس حيث
يشتعل في جسده بالكامل حتى
عيناه مشتعلة ويستيقظ
صراخ صراخ لأمه
لإطفاء اللهب
السلطان قديم قدم الحرب السورية نفسها
حياة تحمل
ندوبًا نفسية وجسدية للأمة
عندما كان في الخامسة من عمره قتل شقيقه الرضيع
في قصف
هذا المكان الذي ولد فيه السلطان.
عنف لا يمكن تصوره
حيث فقد الكثير من بلدة رمادية متربة
من ضحك طفولته مخنوق
سرقته الحرب أه
لم تكن العائلة تعلم أن الألغام كانت
مقيدة بالسلاسل على طول جدار
منزلهم.
يظهر لنا والدها المكان الذي انطلق فيه الأول
، كانت تتأرجح من الباب مع
أشقائها ، ثم فجأة
حدث انفجار من لغم هناك
، فقدت ساقها اليسرى تحت الركبة ،
ولديها أنف اصطناعي
كما تقول.  اختفى والدها قبل عقد من
الزمن في بداية الحرب السورية ،
إنها أطول عقوبة تتحدثها في
الغالب ، تعطي إجابات من كلمة واحدة أو
صمت كاذبًا
يقول جدها إنه يشعر وكأنها أصبحت
فارغة تمامًا ،
فهي لا تحلم بحياة بدون حرب
لأنها تستطيع ذلك.  لا أتخيل حتى
أنه قد مر أكثر من عام منذ أن
كنا هنا في آخر مرة نغطي فيها روسيا
وأشد هجوم للنظام السوري
على ما تبقى من الأراضي التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون ،
كان هناك وقف لإطلاق النار ساري المفعول منذ
ذلك الحين ، والذي كان
يتحدث نسبيًا عن أن
Covet 19 بلغ ذروته  هنا في أواخر العام الماضي ، أصبحت
أسرّة العناية المركزة فارغة في الغالب ، وكلها مغطاة
بأكياس من الرمل تحتها فقط
في حالة وجود
المزيد من القصف الذي يستأنف هذا
المستشفى ، وهو أحد المستشفيات القليلة
المتبقية.  يبلغ عمر
علم ntact شهرين ونصف الشهر ويعاني من
نقص حاد في الوزن ،
وقد شهدوا زيادة بمقدار ثلاثة أضعاف في
حالات سوء التغذية
في هذه العيادة وحدها لعدد من
الأسباب التي أدت إلى
سنوات من القصف والنزوح
مما أدى إلى مزيد من الفقر
ومن ثم تأجيجها 19 حدًا مرغوبًا
عمليات الإغلاق
والمساعدات الإنسانية تتباطأ ،
مررنا بمخيمات متداعية مع كل
قصف ، نسف عدد
أكبر منهم الريف لمدة
عشر سنوات
للعديد من
الصدمات المعقدة
مدى الحياة ، الماضي يتخلل كل شيء بالنسبة لمعظم الناس
، ليس هناك شهر في الأسبوع يمر
وليس هذا هو الذكرى السنوية  من
موت شخص أحبوه
ربما كل ما تبقى لإنقاذه هي
أشلاء
براءة جيل مصاب بالندوب أريوا دامون
سيينا
إدلب سوريا